CCSD has launched a one-of-a-kind
facility it's called The Family Support
Center and it's geared to help students
and their families it's located on
Maryland Parkway and Oaky and the school
district tells me the primary focus
newcomers and undocumented students plus
their families
[Music]
we're going to have mental Services here
soon the Clark County School District
unveiling its new Family Support Center
and 8 news now got a tour of what
families can expect from the medical
center according to CCSD the facility is
part of the rebuilding of global
Community High School which took four
years to complete a 65 million dollar
Community investment they say will focus
on incoming and undocumented students as
myself being someone who didn't speak
English being able to learn with my
parents it was something that changed my
life and through the center we want to
make sure that all students have that
access Astrid Silva is spearheading the
project which she says will offer more
than the basic classroom needs it also
gives us all an opportunity to
contribute different different things
there's different organizations that are
going to be working out of here to
provide those families with resources as
well we are per capita the number one
state in the country per capita with
undocumented families
so the need is here and this is where
the Clark County School District is
going to be here to provide the support
for our families this campus differs
from the other 10 support centers across
the valley according to CCSD because of
its full wrap-around approach from
immunizations eye exams to navigating
the school system and language support
it's exciting that these doors are now
open and the kids can come in
well the services are free to All
Families within CCSD also no
pre-registration is required if we have
a link to all the services and the
programs offered if you're interested on
our website 8newsnow.com